freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
ist es ganz besonders ich bin hier bei
fritz ich bin im weit ich habe einen
camper und alles mitgenommen was ich für
diesen tag heute zum kochen braucht es
wird also wie gesagt wir sind bei fritz
dave es hinter der kamera und leute wir
haben schon im wald übernachtet und das
alles wirklich muss in vetschau dort
gebe es keine bezahlte geschichte also
konnte ich nur machen dann compagnia di
habe mit diesem kemper hier gestellt ich
habe die wirklich angerufen eine stunde
später saß ich in dem camp und wissen
losgefahren so krass deshalb dickes
dankeschön die bauen diese dinger haben
zum frühstück gibt es apfel zimt alles
sachen die relativ einfach zu machen
sind hier im wald fangen wir als erstes
an indem wir einen topf setzen
alles ist hier so ein mega kompakt
gemacht ein kubanischer wirklich
komplett den kühlschrank voll weil sich
natürlich auch wenn ich hier im wald den
wald richtung mit gaskocher herausholen
wir sind jetzt zu viert also dave fritz
tom kennt ihr vielleicht austritt videos
der bau auf diese coole findet und ich
muss mich natürlich um alle kümmern
damit alle versorgt sind bei so einem
tag in weiß wo man verschiedenste
bauprojekte hat also wehrfritz nicht
kennen der bau zum beispiel gerade eine
ultra massive hütte ohne technologie
klar so mit werkzeug ne aber kein
elektrisches werkzeug nichts
hydraulisches einfach nur hasse wird und
da braucht man die energie von einem
axel schimpf zum beispiel
wir müssen ein bisschen umräumen aber
gar kein problem ich hole er selber ein
schneidebrett hervor
das wird noch frisches obst und früchte
geben ob es nicht das gleiche wenn
frisches obst geben
hier kennt man cookies hendric leute
ermutigen hier natürlich die butter und
das ist irgendwie kombinieren dann hat
auch automatisch keinen langen routen
oder sowas wenn man in so ein camper
koch weil man halt einfach nur drei
quadratmeter
ich weiß auch noch nicht wie fritz auf
den ketchup mayo reagieren wird dich
dabei hat irgendwie habe ich das gefühl
das sind sachen die ihr eigentlich nicht
jetzt der wald von fritz ist wirklich zu
nice also es ist wirklich doof und ich
habe gerade da hinter der kamera darüber
sprachen jetzt so richtig verwunschen
sondern einer ecke steht so die finnen
hütte dann ist da das chrom hausen so
ist es möglich hatte so in dieser
weihnachtszeit ist irgendwie special was
ich sagen was leben was wirklich leben
das jetzt auch in der aktuellen zeit
glaube ich einfach so mit einer der
meisten sachen die man machen kann
einfach so drauflos fahren mit einem
camper bringen hier mal die hitze vom
grill runter den ich aufgebaut habe ich
habe etwas vorhaben grill dabei für die
grips gleich und so packen wir die
dinger dann
gouda mutter aus 1000 ja die märchen
temperatur auf jeden fall ich bin glaube
ich auch schon ein guter zeitpunkt um
ein harter brocken dazu zu geben und ihr
müsst euch vorstellt alles alles alles
alles was ich hier benutze auch pfeffer
salz zucker
alles muss man mitnehmen würden wir um
und lass das jetzt ein bisschen
eindecken so ich werde es noch ganz
schnell wasser kochen für einen kaffee
weil ihr kennt mich ja leute auch hier
im wald muss ich meinen gästen kaffee
anbieten auch wenn ich meine geliebte
maschine natürlich mit freibier habe
dann nur so eine kleine arrow presto
hier so langsam alles fertig würde sagen
gelegen auch die sandwiches auch mal ein
bisschen zu heißen
ich habe den eindruck dass hier immer so
sonst hätte ich einfach noch den grill
wende
er hat auf jeden fall schon sehr
inflationär aufgebauten grill und decke
drauf damit das ganze auch schon antwort
ja vorbei ist jetzt auch langsam fertig
brauche ich meinen zimt ich hab kein
problem da kommen jetzt eine gute prise
im trend und honig ein rohr das
verstärkt den weihnachts so krass vor
wird jetzt entscheide ich noch zwei
äpfel effizienz leute
das einzige was ich mitgenommen haben
uns auf jeden fall ein bisschen
eingeschränkt in der bewegungsfreiheit
würde ich mal sagen was gibt es da zu
brauchen
jetzt war es nicht wahrhaben also hier
ist nichts schiefgelaufen gerade ja du
das ist doch mal ja ja klar wir sind
besser abgekratzt
ok also normalerweise ist das übelste
schande für mich naja da draußen im wald
sei nicht so einfach wie zu hause ein
bisschen gasgrill hier sind 2 gasgvv
parallel laufen völlig irre oder
einfache tasse heißes wasser freunde
einfach nur heiß war leicht überfordert
wärst du nicht gekommen hätte ich
einfach mal gemacht
niemandem davon erzählt aber jetzt ist
es so ist es gekommen
es kommen doch nicht so richtig gut ja
es gibt auch jetzt los jetzt gibt es
nicht nur sagen das ist aber wirklich
das wald frühstück oder
also so eine schöne große bowl haferbrei
haben auch politisch zu sagen wenn ich
in der millionenstadt dass jetzt ein
raubtier fütterung natürlich auch in
seiner kantine ist ein bisschen le clos
unbedingt legt los heißt es ich könnte
euch ein gläschen
aber jetzt jacobsen kilo entwicklung mit
minute also das war ein haferflocken mit
zimt chronik apfel gerne dabei jetzt
frisst schon im hinterkopf behalten
du musst nicht bewerten bei der
krankheit arbeiten kann man ja arbeiten
sehr gut der kaffee ist da manchmal
durchgezogen fritz trinkt aber
tatsächlich gar keine absolut unnötig
dann gehe ich bei 8,53 als begründung
weil es einfach ein geiler mix of cars
ein bisschen was herzhaftes sowas aber
auch politisch ein bisschen was süßes
drin ein bisschen gesund wir sind was
ungesundes chemische und dann noch ein
bisschen orangensaft finde ich geil und
wir müssen ja noch potenzial nach oben
ich weiß nicht was noch kommt oder nur
deswegen so 898 beim mittagessen
spaghetti bolognese
so leute ich habe mich bereit gemacht
ihr seht ich sitze hier inmitten von
feinsten zutaten es gibt wie gesagt
spaghetti bolognese und wir fangen wir
an indem wir hier den bauchspeck würfeln
und dann gleich auslassen bauchspeck ich
natürlich von chat aber ich finde jeder
und das klingt 1000 eleganter und besser
wir brauchen davon ungefähr die hälfte
sein ist auch schon wieder zeit für
unseren kopf überkochen
da haben wir unseren großen topf geben
ein wenig olivenöl hinein lassen die
jetzt ein bisschen aus das gibt uns
natürlich dann jede menge geschmack
haben wir uns für eine zwiebel und die
wirken wird fein
dann tischt jetzt hier mal die
farnstädter raus wo leute mühsam alles
hier rausgefischt und jetzt drücken wir
das hat mir schon ein bisschen an und
geben es dann auf den boden dann
brauchen wir jetzt eine stange sellerie
dann firma checken
ja genau so soll es sein so schöneres
herum gekommen
auch die karotten wirken gefallen sodass
wollen jetzt auch raus wenn das alles
rausgeholt ist dann gehen wir das gemüse
dazu einfach alles auf einmal und das
ist auf jeden fall jetzt hier schon in
diesem ganzen schönen gruß ist kein öl
noch mal dazu gekommen oder so sondern
das wird jetzt lasik gegart wenn das
ganze glasig gekocht ist geben wir dazu
drei großzügige fehler tomatenmark und
das ganze lassen jetzt gemeinsam ein
bisschen klebrig werden dann geben wir
ungefähr 200 milliliter weißwein darüber
ein auto und lassen das ganze jetzt
ungefähr die hälfte des volumens
reduzieren jetzt geben wir dazu so einen
esslöffel hühnerbrühe und natürlich noch
ein bisschen wasser weil die kommt ja
eigentlich nicht pulverisiert dann eine
dose gehackten tomaten reinige marseille
und noch mal eine halbe dose weil wir zu
viel dann ist es auch schon soweit wir
fügen alles was wir uns hier an die
seite gestellt haben einfach wieder
hinzu inklusive des saftes und groppen
das hier hinein und dann können wir
jetzt anfangen das ein klein bisschen zu
zerkleinern lassen es aber jetzt einfach
für minimum eine stunde köcheln
dann werden alle zutaten richtig weich
und dann muss nur nudeln kochen und
bekam gleich essen ok nudeln sind
herzlich gekocht polonaise ist fertig
gekocht guck doch mal rein des übels
kassel 500 gramm nudeln hab ich nur
gemacht und dazu gibt es noch jede menge
parmesan und ich richte drüben an
[Musik]
herrlich ist dürfte schon mal sehr gut
erste kabel danach geht die kamera aus
und jetzt zeit zum genießen heute gut
okay leute wir sehen uns gleich es ist
einfach das ist zu schön wenn ich
gespannt haben sie dir gemundet waren
sehr sehr lecker nudeln perfekte
konsistenz gehabt teilte fleißig wird
auf einem grünen gehen wenn man muss er
zehn ist er in stufe ja das einzige was
mir jetzt noch der väter was passiert
ist irgendwie einem pass ist getränkt
eigentlich die drei nur die polonaise
für dich ja zehn was war das für dich
gewesen dazu zum bremsen sonst ihre so
klas wir so um als mittagessen mit zehn
zu haben yao hätte nur eine bootstaufe
beim mittagessen bewertung neuen weil
ich sage trägt was sowieso sehr gut aber
in der neuen leute da kann man sich
wirklich schmecken lassen
ich fand es auch die belecker wir sehen
uns zum abendessen so kommen wir zum
abendessen dave kann ich leider nicht
weiter in der kamera unterstützen weil
er selbst ein richtig heißes video mit
tritt macht das kommt bald es geht
wieder los mit speck pass einfach zur
jahreszeit also glaube ich kein zufall
dass es in zwei rezepten drin ist die
ich ausgewählt habe chris hat mir
nämlich komplett freie hand gelassen für
die auswahl der rezepte
bisher lief sehr gut ich hoffe ich
treffe auch mit der maroden so viel sein
geschmack ihr wisst ja auch ich beende
die folgen immer gerne mit ein bisschen
besonderen sache und machen das ganze
nämlich mit karamellisiertem chicoree
schmeckt rein und direkt ein großzügiger
stich butter dazu 50 gramm oder so zu
als nächstes stehe ich hier starten
[Musik]
so und jetzt lassen wir das ganze mit
einem schluck weißwein und ein bisschen
auch waschen sagt haben außerdem noch
ein bisschen honig eigentlich würde man
zucker dazu fügen aber ich habe leider
kein jetzt kommen wir schon unsere maron
zum einsatz
ich habe hier so eingeschweißt gekauft
man kann man einfach raus klopfen und
die gehen wir dann auch einfach schon
mal dazu
sie sind übrigens überraschend teuer
gewesen keine ahnung 15 euro
unsere mission ist riecht schon sehr
sehr gut muss ich tatsächlich sagen für
mit dem ganzen jetzt einen großen
esslöffel hühnerbrühe hinzu und schütten
750 milliliter wasser hinterher passt so
lernt das ganze köchelt gehen wir hier
noch 12 ästchen filme und ein us marine
notiert ist muss auch noch fett ein
kocht jetzt 20 minuten ein und dann
würde man es halt pürieren fehlanzeige
man wird es stammt die leute während das
hier so vor sich hin köchelt und alle
sachen darin weich werden stammt
verstehe ich schon bereit
ich habe die fahne am start ein kleiner
fun fact die fahne stammt von einem
roadtrip in genau so einem wagen nicht
ganz ohne ist wieder von compania wir
waren mit revisor des apple und so
unterwegs auf dem rotterdamer die
gekauft und jetzt wird sie wieder ihren
ursprünglichen zweck zugeführt
die stelle ich mal wieder an die seite
und dann schneide ich hier eben chicoree
in streifen dass so ein abenteuer hier
eigentlich fällt mir grad nochmal aus
essen draußen zwei grad bin mit coolen
leuten unterwegs bin sehr dankbar
erst mal drauf dann gehen wir den
figuren hinein direktor ea dazu den
lassen wir jetzt hier in so ein bisschen
dünsten und einkommen da kommt dann so
als topping oben auf die suppe hier wird
langsam alles weich jeden fall wird
jetzt hier auch mal zeit sahne
hinzugeben einfach so eine ganze packung
250 gramm führten wir dazu und lassen
wir jetzt mit köchen ich warte noch ein
bisschen aber auch dann ersetzen wir mit
honig den zucker weil eigentlich
da probiere ich hier aber auch schon mal
die gewürze herauszufischen
ich habe jetzt noch einmal kurz position
kann noch weiter runter köpfen aber hier
brauche ich mal den platz und nichts was
ist denn von der temperatur oder zu
gehen und dann fange ich auch schon an
zu stampfen ist göttlich nicht so super
einfach das irgendwie find zu kriegen
kochen stampfen kochen stampfen ist ja
noch ein kleines problem
das vergisst dass ich gestern geburt ist
ein paar
ich werde das jetzt einfach komplett mit
wasser übergießen und auf den grill
legen und hoffen dass ich noch ein
bisschen weich habe komme und angeröstet
und so aber kann sich genauso wie
übrigens auch mich entschlossen das
jetzt noch ein bisschen feiner gemacht
ist dabei zu belassen fachen grober
eintopf ich finde das passt auch einfach
besser ich habe das brot tatsächlich
wieder relativ weich bekommen ich werde
jetzt probieren es noch mal an zu rosten
mit olivenöl so sieht der chicorée
übrigens jetzt aus wie nicht richtig
lecker das war komplett hat aber so ist
jetzt wieder christi und flache
[Musik]
also dann wir sitzen zusammen ist es
mittlerweile dunkel draußen ich habe
euch hier eine maron suppe mit
karamellisiertem chicoree vorbereitet
dazu ein bisschen an geröstetes brot
macht euch gerne schmecken die wir
müssen aber diese schmackes erlebnisse
verarbeiten das ist krank ist also ohne
scheiß du hast geschrieben warum da
dachte ich hier weihnachtsmarkt baron
dachten so 100 das wird nicht und jetzt
esse ich hier vor den riecher denn mir
ist das sehr gut leute das sind glaube
ich gute nachrichten wir sehen uns
bergfrieds gab es hier noch die letzten
reste auf der schiffe bin sehr gespannt
wie es ihr geschmeckt hat es ist ja noch
ein bisschen exotisch ich hatte ja
gerade schon gesagt dass ich anfangs ein
bisschen skeptisch war
dazu fehlt mir auch hier jetzt wieder
noch um passende getränk aber das nehme
ich mal nicht mit rein in die wertung
über das hat man bei mittag schon
und tatsächlich würde ich hier meine
zehn von zehn geben einfach weil es
geschmäcker bauen ich so noch nicht
hatte geil das manchmal komplett
überrascht hat mich echt vorerst voll an
die war ja deswegen bin ich da gibt es
auch mal mit hey leute das ist doch ein
gebührendes ende für diesen tag ich fand
es wirklich also wirklich dank könnt ihr
einige dank dass hier vorbeikommen diana
ganz einfach schön hier
ich finde das hat auch einen kleinen
weihnachtsmarkt gegeben oder sagen das
war ja auch ganz leicht last christmas
demo dabei ja die leute dann will ich
garnicht erweiterung
hier seht ihr die gesamtwertung
eingeblendet vielen lieben dank das hier
sein durfte und wir sehen uns nächsten
sonntag um 14 uhr wieder mach's gut bis
dahin und tschüss
[Musik]